- [voiceover] Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three different, if
interrelated subjects.
The way it's phrased right
over here, the writer is saying
these are three different subjects,
but they're giving a
little bone to the idea.
I admit that they are interrelated.
Even though they are
definitely interrelated,
they are different subjects.
That's how it reads there.
It's not badly written.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three different,
if interrelated, subjects.
It feels a little bit,
a little bit convoluted.
I might want to say that
three different subjects,
although they are definitely
interrelated as well
or something like that.
Let's just look at the other options.
This is as it's written.
Not horrible, but let's think
of a better way to phrase that.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three interrelated subjects
being however different.
That's just convoluted.
The real point of it is
that they're trying to say
that they're different subjects,
although I'm willing
to admit that they are,
they're not completely unrelated.
This one right over here, this one
is emphasizing that they're
interrelated subjects
and giving a little bit bone
to them being different.
This is a different meaning
and it's very convoluted
being however different.
It's unnecessarily they put
all these commas in there
and it's kind of hard
to read and really long.
Let's look at choice C.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three different subjects,
whereas they are interrelated.
Once again, okay.
They're making the point that they're
three different subjects.
Whereas they are interrelated.
I don't know.
Whereas seems kind of
formal, kind of legally.
Whereas they are interrelated.
That also, because of
that convoluted phrasing
and using of whereas seems
a little bit unnecessary.
This definitely not as
good as the first choice.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three different,
if interrelated, subjects.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three different
subjects when interrelated.
That's just definitely wrong.
They're not only different
when they are interrelated.
That's not, that the
completely incorrect meaning.
Intimacy, love, and
marriage are three subjects
that are different although
being interrelated,
although being interrelated.
It starts off okay.
Intimacy, love, and marriage
are three subjects that are different.
If this was a period
and then say and or but
or even it was a comma,
but they are also related,
then something like that
might have been okay,
but although being related.
This is once again, this is kind of
a weird phrase that's
thrown on the end of it.
I'll cross that one out.
Really the best one is it as it's written.
They're three different,
if interrelated subjects.
It's kind of the cleanest.
It's the shortest.
It's getting to the point.
They're different subjects,
although you're giving a
little bone to the idea,
throwing a little bone into the idea.
They are interrelated, but they are
three different subjects.
I'll definitely go with choice A.